we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P I will have more to say
about my appearances in uh Florida last
week including on the Patrick Pat David
show but here is one voicemail about the
pbd podcast appearance
David I just saw your interview with
Patrick that David yes and you nailed it
thank you knocked him out of the park he
did not know his talking points you did
amazing I hope you will continue to do
these kind of interviews including on
Rogan
uh
I'm not sure which other ones you would
do but this guy who seems to think he
knows what he's talking about right and
he's confronted by facts and he's
knocked down
and you do it in a respectful way I
think those are the kind of interviews
you need to keep doing and I hope you
keep doing them love the show peace out
well listen I received both positive and
negative comments about the pbd
appearance I actually do think I could
have been better prepared in some areas
I didn't know what he was going to talk
to me about but there were areas where I
felt I could have been better prepared I
think it went okay you know the thing
about doing a lot of these especially
the ones that are in person is it's a
ton of work and last week I was I was on
vacation anyway so it sort of worked out
but often in order to do a single
podcast appearance I have to miss
usually it's like two days of the show
we need guest hosts all of this stuff
costs money Logistics Etc so it's it's
really a logistical limitation and they
are more compelling when I'm in person
than than via Skype like I understand
that so I'm hoping to do more The Lex
Friedman thing got canceled Lex canceled
that I don't know that Rogan's
interested in ever having me on again
but
we're going to try to keep doing a mix
of stuff and we will be publishing uh
the pbd podcast with my comments very
soon and I appreciate everybody's
thoughts on uh on on how it went we have
a fantastic bonus show for you today Ted
Cruz wants a two-term limit for senators
but he wants a third term remember the
rules don't apply to him right uh we
will talk about a ban on marijuana users
owning guns being found unconstitutional
by the ruling of a judge and we will
talk about limiting sugar in school
meals for the first time how has this
not happened before all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show use your
machine to sign up at joinpakman.com
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines yes sign up before
pillow takes your machine and you can
use the coupon code 24 starts now to get
a discount it's great to be back I will
see you on the bonus show or otherwise
tomorrow